my name's peter santaniello and i'm
sitting on a park bench
in key of ukraine and it's a long story
of how i got here but the short story is
i'm from san francisco and
an opportunity presented itself where i
could live here and i took that
opportunity because well this is a
radically different place it couldn't be
any more different than living in san
francisco now i'm living in kyiv
but i'm about to go on this
very interesting journey into the
unknown
and which is a place called asupenko
ukraine and it's near berdansk
near the azov sea in the south
and i'm living with a family i don't
know this family they seem cool though
they're taking me in for the summer
it's to document
this lifestyle
can't really be
replicated in the west
[Music]
at the vauxhall the train station in
kiev ukraine
and uh not your normal day of travel for
me going to verdonsk
[Music]
today didn't go as is as expected um
as we can see here there's a bike seat
coming out of the box because i lost my
x tool
well it's on it doesn't matter now
i'm taking a train called plast card
something like that
and uh a few people laughed when i said
that
i don't know what that means
but i'm interested i'm really excited
for this plus card experience
[Music]
made it
and i'm putting myself completely out of
my own world in a day i lose my language
completely for six weeks
i think whenever you take yourself
outside your comfort zone your normal
world you take yourself outside of your
language and your
your collection of friends and
everything that you've established at
home
there's
challenges that come with that i
remember the first week i uh i couldn't
even say the name of my street volvarno
cooperate
what are you working
class
but my goal is to pick up
the languages as quickly as possible
through
immersion and struggle
and the reason i'm doing i'm learning
russian and not ukrainian is because i
have a lot of russian friends in san
francisco we take trips together i want
to go to a lot of the four other former
soviet countries and use the language so
it's it's beneficial for me but if i
stay here longer
definitely the
ukrainian also
[Music]
my name is
in my first hour on class cart and plus
cart is actually pretty cool it's like
very communal
and very social and everyone sort of
just puts their things out chills reads
books drinks beer eats chocolate
and uh
i like it i like the flash card
ladies do you mind if i show the traffic
situation
here okay these are my uh bunk mates in
the plast cart
and
we have another other member uh i don't
know if she's sleeping yet or just
getting a nap
but uh
she was a very nice woman very helpful
in the beginning but
here's the deal here's the situation you
put
all your stuff under the seat
so i guess that's
nobody jacks it at night when you're
sleeping
and
we paid the uh the administration office
on the end of the cabins uh
a little bit of money to watch the bike
tonight so i think that's going to keep
it safe they said they were on it and it
wouldn't be it wouldn't get out
without them going down with a fight so
i think the bike's good
[Applause]
plus card
some of the
some of the small sacrifices you make on
flashguard you might have to remove some
old tissues or whatnot but
definitely um not a big deal
oh nice pillow
even a pillow
fresh clean sheets
[Music]
this thing must be so hot when it's
actually hot out we got lucky it's
pretty cool
it's like a very cool snap in the middle
of summer
but uh
it's hot as it is
if it was hot this would definitely be a
sweater
[Music]
so
foreign
[Music]
this is the end
it's the final stop this is
verdansk
[Laughter]
so uh the second i get off this train
the very moment i get off english
finished six weeks
the rules of the game daily diary some
facebook live
studying russian google translate
that's it i can't listen
i can't read
i can't speak
english
finished completely
and uh
[Music]
you